In looking through
the UI View Controller record category,
you may have noticed a method
called convert video to GIF.
This is where the magic happens.
Let's see here.
It's using a class called regift.
What's that?
Regift was written as
a Cocoapod by Matthew Palmer.
And it does exactly what we need.
It converts a video into a GIF.
If you look into the GIF
maker objective C folder,
you'll see a folder
called third party code.
If you open up that folder,
you'll see another folder called Regift,
that's where we've included
the files directly in the project.
We've also added these files
to the swift project template.
Here's Matthew Palmer's read me for
regift on GitHub.
And in the Quick Start guidelines, we
can see that to initialize an instance
of the regift class,
we need to pass in four parameters.
The video URL, the frame count,
delay time, and loop count.
Go back into your swift project and
add frame count, delay time, and
loop count at the top of the UI View
Controller extension file as constants.
We'll start with these defaults for
now but
you can experiment with different
values to suit your liking.
Next we'll add a method
called convertVideoToGIF
which uses the regift class.
In this method will create
an instance of the class regift.
In the read me,
we can see that this line of code
initializes an instance of regift.
The method that creates the GIF
is named appropriately createGIF
if we open up the regift.swiftFile.
We can see they create gift returns
in NSURL to the newly created GIF.
So go ahead and create a variable called
GIFURL to store the return value and
now that in theory we
have a URL to a GIF.
Let's test it out by displaying
it in the GIF editor.